thank you very much for our sponsor for
today Nord VPN and for all of our
viewers you get 75% off a three-year
plan and with the coat JK news you get
one month extra for free so people be
like wait where is it I'll tell you what
is for I knew that this was really gonna
come in handy for me cuz I travel a lot
or like just I'm on the go like I'm not
always home right so sometimes I need it
like access my bank account and I feel
super paranoid doing this like on an
unsecured Network so if I'm at the
airport or the library or just like
Starbucks or anything like I just feel
kind of weird about doing it but I'm
crying there's always that Eastern
European guy with the leather jacket on
looking at you from the side looking
like a mob boss with a jumpsuit in a
gold necklace and a cigarette in his
mouth yeah I know are you gonna hack my
stuff yeah but I also don't want to be
like you know stereotypical about people
so I don't want to do that but I'm also
very scared that anybody could come into
my computer get all of my pictures of my
nudes and all that stuff and I'm all
exposed out into the world
and those you know are special to me
yeah and that's why we gotta use this
yeah especially any time you log on like
at a college campus or anywhere that has
a free public Wi-Fi it's an unsecured
Network so it is possible that people
can hack any of your password
information or banking information or
anything like that so having noir VPN
protects you from those hackers and you
know how crazy quality this is they have
military-grade encryption that's like
top-level that's like a bulletproof vest
that's like the ultimate protection yeah
and they really care about your
satisfaction because having 30-day
money-back guarantee so go right now to
Nord VPN comm /jk news or even easier
check our description box below clickety
click that link and you can get three
years of noir VPN for 75% off and an
extra month fo free but about a big bang
we use our code JK news that's right
[Music]
action you got a beef jerky that's like
the worst snack to be [ __ ] on this
guy over here tune in take my breath
away News
[Music]
submitted by Lord knows a man went on a
karaoke marathon so intense
he's lung collapse Oh was it baby no
baby no no Korean no yeah oh come on 40
you know what you say what no and I read
him and I did just it was just a
marathon I just pulled out 48 hours for
some work so the 65 year old Chinese man
65 yeah he sing 10 songs straight
ignoring the pain that he had in his
chest when he's not speaking from the
diaphragm that's why I mother was he
just seeing it like he rented his own
karaoke room for himself
yeah it's just ten songs but you know
only get a marathon in a row oh yeah
less than an album dude like what the
[ __ ] yeah it's like an hour or less that
is a long time with sneakers no brakes
though yeah if you sing him properly
no he said yeah so he was singing a lot
of songs was like really high note it
was all Mariah Carey huh 65 years old
[Laughter]
don't drink I'm picturing that fat
Chinese kid that could kill it with
[ __ ] whitney houston's it you gotta be
it
you gotta visualize the [ __ ] note
sorry I'm reading stop you know Sammy
you're the reason why we got this line I
was like what okay see that fortune you
are the reason you're the reason that
you're the reason she's like don't look
over it you're the reason that word
what's weird is like a lot of these
Asians that do karaoke right when they
speak English it's all [ __ ] up I love
Joe with him with us at all I completed
the thought and I moved on yeah but
they're singing sounds perfect yes you
got me right yeah what the [ __ ] how is
that possible even British people
they're good at mimicking exactly what
they hear ya know like they have thick
accents right like Filipinos or a
Chinese RA anything yeah but then but
then when they sing an English song it's
perfect like the jalapeno dude that took
over the lead singer of journey does he
have an accent
yeah he kills it yeah yeah he sounds
like they did a like like what do you
call that like oh my god or old don't
act surprised you've reported that story
I did
oh yeah she's so surprised I was taking
those brain supplements right exactly
I was trying to find that words okay and
then I forgot to take up for a whole
week and then now I'm back to square one
we help you a little bit you feel like
well I think it's my action you're
working now and not really the pills but
it just yeah because I was doing both
that's it both OH
also sleep how much sleep do you get I
gave it cause if you're usually getting
if you're used to getting eight hours
and then like you go down to like a
couple days of like six hours or five
hours or something didn't have five
hours last night yeah that's probably
what it is girl yeah yeah five hours
sleep cuz you're like what's going on
cuz you in your head you think you get
eight hours a day but then my Fitbit was
keeping track of my sleep and I'm like
oh usually getting hours but last week
there was only five hours average oh and
also now they're figuring out that a lot
of people are not hitting their rims so
you'll be sleeping eight hours but
you're not getting deep sleep how are
you not like what's happening too late
really there's a lot of factors yes yes
not enough water affects your sleep
I've been killing it in the water
department I went to pee like six times
today already if your husband comes in
and just randomly takes the covers off
you cuz he's he's asleep already
so no Steve I will come in and full-on
just take all the covers off me go to
sleep you why do you think we used to
blank you oh that makes sense
um yeah and then I'm like yo give me my
blankie
he's completely past that yeah whole
like floppy arm on me there's you you
leave the TV on when you sleep
I refuse to fall asleep with the TV do
you feel weird right when you wake up
yeah I feel like my body didn't read
that's why because yeah you're fine is
still working while you're kind of
sleeping and it's not hitting the REMS
damn I can knock the [ __ ] out with the
TV in the bedroom yeah what were you
sleep better if you turn it off I mean I
do this I do well just put it on a sleep
timer
well when I really when I want to try
and force like um I am it hours asleep
no no no no a lucid dream which I
haven't been able to doing along [ __ ]
your drinks yeah all that [ __ ]
turn the TV off [ __ ] bury that [ __ ]
man I just want to fly I like you to
both were like yeah [ __ ] well both
crying yeah [ __ ] lines pretty little
weird but good in science yeah I got to
run everything off and just [ __ ] bury
my face in like pillows and then I kind
of hit that that needed REM for the
loosen you have to have REM to get lucid
dreams for me it has to be like a really
deep sleep oh yeah you could control
that I've gotten close like where it's
like um if I usually it happens when I
sleep on my back as opposed to my side
because I feel like I sleep deeper on my
back me too yeah yeah yeah yeah so and I
just kind of try and like when I feel
myself dreaming and I may be about to
wake up I just have to keep reminding
myself to stay out stay asleep and then
I kind of can force myself into it
that's tight
yeah I'm only gonna a handful of times
though my tongue ends up like I choke
myself you get sleep apnea - that's
probably what it is
I do is that what it is like my tell you
me not be able to breathe that's a huge
I guess like epidemic or problem that a
lot of people are dealing with now yeah
so sleep apnea has been kind of [ __ ]
people up with their sleeps some people
got sleep apnea machines looks like that
I like being in a jet I mean I know
about sleep apnea what exactly happens
you choke but like what's your breathing
because your tongue and your muscles
here get relaxed to the point where you
choke on your tongue or it can be like a
variety of reasons like if you smoke or
whatever I like it [ __ ] up your
breathing patterns or your your lungs
get smaller the capacity or if you gain
weight suddenly you get visceral fat and
it pushes all the organs around and it
shortens your breathing span and your
that's what I had it when I was balding
in fact I would have sleep apnea like
every single night where it that's when
you're snoring gets harder you're
choking going on well I mean we got a
space
that's right you know can had sleep
apnea too and he barely snored and if he
did it was like really like that but
yeah so when your tongue goes back while
you're sleeping it's relaxed I don't
happens when I'm laying on my back
though that's why I always sleep on my
side
yeah they recommend sleeping on the side
so this dude sing too much and he has
lung exploded oh yeah yeah I was trying
to be like okay so we're talking about
the body how can i what did he die daddy
no he did not die so he did so he ended
up singing through those all those full
[ __ ] he's like I must finish the blue
damn pipes his heart will go on so he
ignored the pain and then he went home
that night and the next day he decided
to go to the hospital and that's when he
found out that he suffered from a lung
collapse because of the high lung
pressure caused by singing high notes oh
I don't think I'm gonna sing where I
carry anymore he said that a collapsed
lung could be life-threatening but he
was okay he slept with the collapse I
want to know why what party he was like
was he by himself or was he like
performing yeah like why would he have
the mic that long yeah everyone else is
like oh god [ __ ] those guys again Larry
again hogging them live for 10 songs I
don't collapse of the you are alone back
in the day on the way back day like you
would get crazy elements and like people
wouldn't know what was wrong with you
but it was like you were starving or
like you ate bacteria or something like
that and then now it's like your lungs
alone collapse because you sing too much
I know oh I know you think we died for
the stupidest reasons now like back then
it's like I died because I protected my
family from other warriors coming into
my village
yeah now I die because like you take a
[ __ ] selfie I took oh I took a selfie
fall for bridge right damn I was trying
to go viral and then I got killed I was
a killer clown and a prank video and so
much time
those are conversations from heaven
that's crazy
I think too much Mariah Carey I say it
too much and I blew my lungs and died I
went I threw the trash on something cut
me know so they're saying that a
collapsed lung can sometimes heal itself
why but other times a chest tube is
required to help remove the air from the
pleural space and to allow the lung to
re-inflate itself tell us he's gonna be
able to see again please yeah please not
whoever used the karaoke King but I do
know that his thing is his name is Wayne
I said I think Oh sing his way yeah okey
Kang that joke never gets old Wang to
karaoke Kang know we made it up kind of
right your man was uh his his pen name
was Harry Wayne oh yeah Cho Cho Chang
Sheng Wang is it a lot of pain pain man
does he sing
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]